every country on this planet has a story
about its founding
whether it's about a group of rebels
trampling the global superpower
or a pacifist delivering independence
for the second largest country on the
planet the most powerful man of the 20th
century or some dude pulling out a sword
from a rock
they're usually somewhat fabricated and
polished ideas of where the country came
from what it stands for
but china's story is different china's
story is a news story and it is tightly
controlled
[Applause]
it's a story that is being used as a
weapon a weapon to subjugate millions of
people to eliminate ancient cultures to
expand china's borders farther than
they've ever pushed before
it's a founding myth that can't be
challenged within china and it has been
so heavily peddled and thoroughly
implanted into the chinese psyche that
most people believe that china actually
looks like this and that it has always
looked like this
but china doesn't look like this
china actually looks a lot more
like this but only if you look at the
real history the facts and the evidence
which is something you can't really do
within china so instead the communist
party has created and weaponized the
myth of this over the past 70 years to
erase these borders to build islands to
threaten neighbors and to undertake one
of the largest assimilation projects in
human history it's a project that has
cost them trillions of dollars and has
been responsible for countless horrific
human rights violations all in the name
of preserving a pretend version of
history a version that china believes
will keep the communist party in power
and make china the richest most powerful
country on earth
and what's scary is
it just might work
this is the history of the ccp xi
jinping does not want you to know
several mosques have been destroyed in
china's far western region of xinjiang
xinjiang
one of xinjiang's holiest sites is not
only cracking down on muslims but on
other religions as well one of the most
common sites is the chinese leader's
smiling face one of the world's most
ambitious construction projects is going
on in secret we will not let foreign
journalists visit
okay pause for a second i need to thank
today's sponsor because that's how i am
able to make these videos thank you
nordvpn who is a long time supporter of
this channel a vpn is a really cool tool
that allows me to connect to the
internet through a different country
this is cool because not only can i like
stream netflix like that's not available
in my country but is available in like
the uk but also i've been traveling
lately and when i'm in like korea which
i just was and i try to connect to my
gmail or a bunch of other things that
i'm logged into
all of these accounts freak out because
they're like someone in korea is trying
to hack into your email and i'm like no
they're not it's me so i just now
reroute my connection to the us and my
gmail and everything is happy that is
one reason i use nordvpn but nordvpn has
become this way bigger threat protection
tool it has all these great features
like blocking malware or malicious ad
trackers it generates strong passwords
for you it's just like a super useful
tool and all of this is incredibly easy
to use it's all one click away super
easy super user-friendly there's a
reason why nordvpn is like the leading
vpn out there right now they're having a
30-day money-back guarantee and if you
go to the link in my description which
is nordvpn.com johnny harris you can get
an exclusive nordvpn deal plus one month
for free to just check it out
using that link helps support this
channel too so do us both a favor go
click it go check it out and with the
internet from around the world and be
safer about it thank you nordvpn for
supporting this channel for supporting
this video
now let's dive into this kind of heavy
but important story about china
okay before we dive in i want to just
make it clear that i'm aware that all
countries do this thing this thing of
weaponizing their history to make
themselves look good and totally justify
terrible things
i hate to kill you this video is about
china you seem a decent feather i hate
to die so i keep talking about this
chinese narrative this chinese myth
what is it
well
you could hear me talk about it or we
could go right to the horse's mouth and
listen to this guy xi jinping who's
probably the best salesman for the
chinese story here he is giving a speech
where he starts out with his boldest
claim of all that china is this 5 000
year old civilization with a history of
more than 5 000 years our nation created
a splendid civilization but according to
his story in 1840 outsider europeans
came in and tore apart his unified
country china was plunged into the
darkness of domestic turmoil and foreign
aggression and now china is fighting
back we must be ready to fight build our
ability and keep striving to secure new
victories in this struggle so the modern
communist party of china is engaged in a
project to restore the greatness of
china to make china great again okay
right but this is just a political
speech why do we care if this guy's
romanticizing the history a little bit
it doesn't really matter right no
actually it does matter bam
what i want to show you is that xi
jinping and the communist party use this
story to justify terrible things
mass assimilation of people to be
controlled by the central government of
beijing so to do this let me just
quickly go back and we can do a time
lapse of this region of asia and what it
looked like over the past few thousand
years to sort of fact-check xi jinping
here is china
cradle of civilization in asia what we
think of as chinese culture or chinese
civilization has indeed been around for
thousands of years it was born here
along the yangtze river where a lot of
the language political systems writing
art all of those traditions sort of
originated but from there the idea of a
contiguous unified china becomes kind of
a myth i'm going to put the modern
borders of china on this map so that you
can see what really is happening here
over thousands of years if you were to
look at this territory you would see all
sorts of land configurations looking at
this you can see that china goes from
these periods of unity to periods of
total division
over the past several thousand years
china has gone from a bunch of divided
kingdoms to periods of total unity where
lots of good things happen technology
agriculture unity power during times of
division bad things happened the country
was in chaos there was destruction there
was war there was lawlessness and this
just keeps on happening for thousands of
years a seemingly endless cycle of unity
and then division xi jinping is very
right that out of this region during
some of these unified periods came like
real serious advancements in shipping
and math and like gunpowder and all of
these things that like have informed how
we've all developed as a world this part
of eastern asia was definitely on the
forefront but it was never one
contiguous china for thousands of years
and the upshot was very clear unity
meant prosperity and technology and all
these good things and disunity equals
chaos and bad things okay so it's now
the 1700s and over in europe the new fad
is imperialism
european countries who are looking for
more land so that they can expand their
borders send their armies and everyone's
doing it it's the french it's the
british it's the spanish it's even the
japanese are starting to get on board
with this and over here in today what we
call china they had once again slipped
into a period of serious disunity they
were divided but this time it came with
an extra dose of humiliation it's not
for nothing that the period stretching
around 100 years from the 1840s to the
1940s is known as china's century of
humiliation this era of disunity in
china came from outsiders
[Music]
you can see this political cartoon all
of these barbarians at the door vying to
carve up and slice up china for their
own profit china was once again in the
dumps and it was here while european and
japanese powers were dividing up their
land that china learned its second
crucial lesson not just that unity is
better but that if you want to survive
in this brave new world you have to play
by the new rules and those rules were
very clearly laid out by these european
empires defined borders a patriotic
agenda assimilating other cultures into
their own this was the playbook the
europeans were playing by and it was
working
[Music]
okay so fast forward now it's like the
1900s it's the beginning of the
communist revolution that would
eventually envelop this entire country
the communist leaders were small still
at this point and they used this century
of humiliation and division as well as
this general lesson of
unity equals prosperity to rally the
people for a new cause the
revolutionaries are like we've been
sliced up and divided by all of these
foreign powers and when we're divided we
fail remember exhibit a b and c so these
communist leaders went off and created
this grand vision of a united china a
story that china had actually always
been united they framed it in terms of
this former glory of what china used to
be what it was before the outsiders came
in a grandiose vision of the past that
never really existed i mean again this
sounds pretty darn familiar we will make
america strong again proud again safe
again great again and that became the
grand plan of the communist revolution
in china to make china united again
despite the fact that china had never
really been fully united not like this
but the story this vision was a potent
rallying cry china would never be cut up
again never humiliated it would have
defined borders
ethnic purity cultural assimilation and
so for the last 70 years that's the
great project that china and the
communist party have been undertaking
creating their own great empire
controlled by a central authority this
project has coincided with china getting
rich pulling 100 million people out of
poverty and becoming a global superpower
all just in a few decades all of this
has given the government a lot of
resources with which to execute their
project of forcefully uniting a swath of
land that isn't and has never been
united and i want to show you what that
looks like the issue of china ruling
over autonomous regions is controversial
so what are china's autonomous regions
and are they really all that autonomous
this is the map that most people are
familiar with when they think of china
but this outline doesn't tell you the
whole story because nearly half of this
land is considered autonomous
super jargony turn what does that even
mean there are over 56 ethnicities in
china most of them concentrated far away
from beijing like over here in tibet or
over here in xinjiang when those
communist leaders were setting up their
new unified china empire they kind of
admitted like okay there are a lot of
cultures and languages and identities
within this country we should let these
people govern themselves not entirely of
course they still have to answer to
beijing with certain things but they
would have autonomy autonomous regions
but many of these semi-autonomous
regions like xinjiang tibet and southern
mongolia these places were never
originally a part of any conception of
china they were forcefully absorbed by
the chinese communist party
during its nation-building project like
in the past 70 years okay let's get
specific here
xinjiang is a region that is very far
from beijing not just geographically but
also culturally
it is a huge region roughly the size of
alaska has 25 million people and half of
those people identify as uyghur which
are mostly muslims who are from a turkic
descent not like a tan chinese descent
they come from a different culture the
street signs are not in any chinese
language they're in like the uyghur
turkic language the architecture looks a
lot more at home in like istanbul than
it does in beijing and five times a day
the streets fill with the sound of
prayer xinjiang was an independent
republic twice before but eventually it
was overthrown by china eight years
after china grabbed xinjiang the chinese
government did the same thing to an even
more remote region at the highest
plateau in the world tibet
they annexed this place that is three
times the size of texas it has its own
very distinct language cultural identity
and does not identify or connect with
beijing and back in the day again when
china wasn't rich and powerful they
couldn't really wrangle these regions
until suddenly they got rich really fast
second in gdp only to the united states
and for the past 30 to 40 years china
has been pouring money and people into
these two regions to make them more like
china it's kind of like the geopolitical
version of gentrification it's basically
where non-chinese societies are subsumed
by societal norms of han chinese culture
because of a bunch of militarization and
money so in tibet you see this in the
tibetan schools that are only teaching
in mandarin not in the traditional
tibetan language or you see it in
xinjiang where the mosques are torn down
for being too islamic and are rebuilt in
traditional chinese styles
oh and it starts to get a lot worse in
xianjiang the uyghurs are literally
taken away by the millions and forced
into concentration camps where they're
supposedly forcibly taught chinese
values the government is involved in a
mass sterilization project where they
are forcibly inserting iuds and other
birth control forms to basically run
them into extinction and not just like
10 people like millions of people china
originally gave these people autonomy
because they recognized that they had
their own culture and they wanted to
retain it but now they've totally thrown
that deal out the window the way this
presents most commonly in these regions
is just the presence of military and
police there are checkpoints everywhere
there's restricted movement there's
constant surveillance and every year
that passes by it becomes harder these
people resist they fight back they
commit acts of terror and in response
china sends more military more police
and more surveillance equipment in 2018
china spent 10 billion dollars in
security
in xinjiang
that's almost double the year before
and 10 times as much as it was 10 years
previous three billion of those dollars
go into these re-education camps that's
four times more than the previous year i
mean it's ramping up they're pouring
money into these regions per person
china spends 3 100 yuan on security in
tibet 2 400 in xinjiang per person
compare that to the national average of
763 yuan per person and you can see that
every single person in these regions is
worth a lot more in terms of the cost of
making them assimilate so the question
is why
why is china doing this why are they
investing so much money into occupying
and forcibly assimilating these people
well there are several geopolitical and
economic reasons why the communist party
wants to do this first off the resources
xinjiang produces 87 of the country's
cotton for example and when it comes to
tibet you can see that they provide a
buffer between china and india tibet
also has the largest fresh water supply
in the world
given where they are so high up china
also uses these regions as a part of
their big infrastructure initiative the
belton road initiative they use
infrastructure to connect these regions
to continue to fortify their economic
standing in the world but i believe the
real reason is this myth this myth of a
united china because a united china is a
strong china a divided china is a
chaotic china this has been the rallying
cry for 70 years but it's not just
assimilation within their borders this
myth has also fueled and justified
china's adventures in expansion
elsewhere this is the south china sea
china says it will fight to the very end
to prevent taiwan from being declared
independent the former british colony is
being smashed into submission so now you
have china building islands in the south
china sea claiming that this entire
ocean belongs to them oh that's just
china reclaiming what was rightfully
theirs because after all this ocean's
been theirs for five thousand years
they're just reclaiming it violating its
promise to let hong kong stay
independent and absorbing it into china
piece by piece oh that's just china
restoring sovereignty over these islands
that britain's stolen like the 1800s how
about an invasion of taiwan to unite it
forcibly with china all they're doing is
restoring china back to the way it was
but again
this was never the case this is a story
constructed 70 years ago to unify a
country that was on the brink of
collapse this story today is weaponized
and used by xi jinping and the communist
party to justify almost everything that
they're doing achieving national
rejuvenation will be no walk in the park
it will take more than drum beating and
the gong clanging to get there every one
of us in the party must be prepared to
work even harder toward this goal okay
so to end this i just want to say one
last thing which is i have no interest
in bashing on china and chinese culture
there's so much beauty that comes from
this region of the world
and as i mentioned every one of the
countries out there including my own are
guilty of a weaponized history the
reason i'm concerned and focused on this
is because
this mythical fake story that china is
using it can't be fact checked within
china so instead the chinese government
is able to use this story as a weapon to
justify the oppression of its people the
grabbing of land and honestly looking at
it how it's playing out it's just a
modern day version
straight out of the old european
imperialistic handbook
[Music]
you